[Music]
big date doc you made a mistake by
letting me sit on this side of the table
I actually prefer the echo to the demon
boys welcome everyone back to the Jimmy
Julian podcast is brought to you by lift
right now guys if you want to earn money
drive your car have a good time make
tips make your own schedule sign up for
lyft they're looking for new drivers
right now if you're trying to choose a
ride share and coming into drive Ford go
with them the company that believes in
treating you better which is lyft guys
right now if you go to ly ft.com slash
Genet Julian you can sign up and get a
new five hundred dollar driver bonus how
amazing is that make your own hours to
drive people have a good time go to lift
thank you lift thank you so much wow my
god okay this is the first Skype
interview guest that we've ever had I'm
really excited I'm proud that we did
this there was a little bit of it was a
lot of coordination yeah so when you see
the interview we're not sitting in here
because our PC would not let OBS and
Skype have it at the same time OBS and
spat there have you would not they would
not coexist they were having a rumba
night fight and so we did it in the
office so yeah so just to be clear we
just finished talking to esto also known
as Eric's store from Eric's store
productions from for those who don't
know I know a lot of you have been
waiting specifically for this podcast
and I told you we were gonna try our
best to make it happen and we did Eric
agreed Eric agreed so I made a video on
my main channel on jenna Marbles what
you looking for um called Google deep
dive with me too
and Julia and I were just like roaming
around on the internet and we actually
typed in the words fire drill fail and
saw a thumbnail on the side that looked
a little too good to be true it looked
hysterical and we found a channel called
s Oh 1 2 1 1 1 1 2 1 1 2 1 say and his
name is Eric store he made us laugh so
hard he
like 12 years 12 he said when he was
making those videos there all four years
old at least yeah we have posted in a
long time and then uh I mean you can
watch that but then what happened what
unfolded on the internet was that his
mom made a video that was like well
before this many of you know the
response was like not only did we get a
huge kick out of his content all of the
people that watched your videos the same
like everyone agreed it was unanimous
like amazing like very entertaining like
where is this kid that was the number
one question where is he
and so his mom made a video that was
like Eric's camping right now he doesn't
have access to his phone like he's just
totally out in the wilderness he has no
idea this is happening but I'll let him
know when he gets back and like yeah so
we so we like waited yeah and waited for
him to come back into civilization right
and and he is a freshman in college so
we did want to make sure that we were
being respectful of Eric's time so it's
not like the longest interview in the
whole world but he's at school right now
and we made it happen we got to talk to
ask oh yeah Eric told this one he was
available and we made it happen yeah
so what you're gonna watch on this
podcast is next you're gonna see the the
about 20 minute long interview that we
just did with Eric store he's like Jenna
said he's at his dorm room at university
is going to school in Canada I like
aliens well as soon as I saw him yeah
and he was just like so gracious and
sweet and like thankful but yeah you
hear I mean this is what this is what
you guys have asked for and we really
desperately want to make it happen and
we did so I guess yeah without further
ado Eric's tour from Eric's tour
productions this is crazy
yes yeah I see thank you so much I'm
feeling all right you know how are you
guys
we're doing we're good this is really
funny I can't even believe that we're
doing this right now um are you at
school right now did you are you yes
I'm at university right now in Canada
this is my dorm room actually like the
corner of it you just move in I've been
here for two weeks now so yeah it was
two weekends ago when I moved in getting
settled nice John settled we're pretty
good classes just happened that homework
but nothing it's good oh my god there's
so many questions
yeah so how did you get started making
videos so that was a really long time
ago actually um like way back in
elementary school probably like third
grade
so I don't even know how old it was it
was probably like 12 or 13 years like I
was talking like five or said no no no
no I was like seven or eight yeah so it
was like 10 10 years ago yeah it's
probably when I started and I was just
like I don't know why but we had like
very old like clunky camcorder you know
like like the little like zoom thing on
the side and so I was just like kind of
play with it and like record random
things and then like in third or fourth
grade um me and one of my best friends
we like decided to start making these
dumb videos I guess and like without
editing of any sort so we would just
record them and then what was recorded
which recorded we didn't really share it
on any platform because I didn't really
know about YouTube back then or anything
and does it not like I don't have those
videos that they're not made but nothing
the very start of me making videos and
then as I went into middle school I
created YouTube channel and like esta
102 one and then I started like filming
my own videos and actually editing them
like I would watching YouTube videos
about how to edit like how do you use
like Adobe Premiere or like how do you
use like Final Cut or whatever and yeah
I just like learned for myself like as I
wanted to do effects like how do you do
a green-screen like in general and then
like how do you add like fire effects to
a video something like that so so that's
that's like amazing that
you so that's all your edit that's all
you know yeah yes it has 100 than me
like self-taught sounds like maybe
someones helping him like babies mom or
dad is helping them but no you did all
of that yourself good you do not know
how to use computers that well did you
have any sort of like influence from
people in your life that maybe wanna
like pursue making videos well it was
just like you found the camera and you
just wanted to go there well originally
originally it was just like I found a
camera and like I always liked that I
always like enjoyed computer like using
computers and stuff like when I was a
kid I was like okay like I don't even
know how to use a computer but I would
like go and then just like try to make a
PowerPoint show or something like that
like in I would into like acting I'm not
gonna be like I was a kid like I was in
the like elementary school plays and all
that and then um but no other than that
I didn't really have like a specific
influence like again in middle school
when I decided to make my youtube
channel it was like because um I watched
like video like channels like nigahiga
like Ryan Higa or like those kind of
channels like I just like watching those
like okay this is funny like this on
YouTube I can also go onto YouTube
because like I'm a regular Tristan so
yeah that's awesome and so I want to
know this is the story I want to go so
when we found your channel and make a
video on it yeah I want to know on your
end
how about wet cuz we can move off the
grid is that true that is true so uh it
was there's a lot so I was actually I
was hiking with my dad and my brother
for five days in the Colorado wilderness
to Colorado and we do it the purpose for
our trip was like okay Eric's about to
go to college for the next four years so
we won't be able to see him like
regularly so like let's go specifically
without some work without our phone so
we can all like focus on each other and
like all that so it was like I think is
actually the second day I was in the
woods when your video came out but of
course I know
idea whatsoever so this is like whatever
like life went on was in the void
well then yeah so when we came out of
the woods like actually we went to the
car first and then it's like 30 minute
drive before there's cell service even
so but then once he like came into cell
service before like facebook
notifications like Instagram all those
like app notifications first I got just
regular like SMS text messages and it
was like it's like not that many people
have my like legit phone number cuz like
I use like apps of everyone but so my
cousins and like my mom and like all
these different people message me like
links to this video like on YouTube and
it's like oh my god Eric you're famous
now like a lot of ice creams and very
sounds like it did like someone hacked
all my like family's phone number that's
like what is going on like like you know
it's always like those like spam things
on facebook will send you a message like
hey Eric exclamation mark and like a
bank to like but I went to click on it
actually and I was like on like 1x
service or whatever so I could have
opened the video so I was like I don't
know what this is but then as he like
went further than further out of the
wilderness all my messages like coming
into my phone my phone was like getting
really high like and freezing and I'm
like a probably good for one like
something as though it's just to be able
to handle that kind of thing but hey
look
freezing up I was like what but in any
kid I just ended up calling my mom and I
was like what is going on like what
happened
and she's like oh no like YouTube famous
like nice even like Jenna's really had
fun yeah like I I knew I had it like
beforehand can you guys work I just like
get mad at people who like before even
telling you about how his famous they're
like I don't know if you know he's like
Janet and Julian people are but they
like discover you but yeah I knew who
you were but basically my mom just tried
to explain it I was like what the heck
and then and then I found out my mom
made some videos I was like at first
like lately embarrassed by them but then
I like understood like her purpose like
it really um but like after after I like
realized everything and I got back to
the
so I think I actually I waited to watch
your video I like didn't even while I
was like I don't even want to know what
I'm till after I'm like showered and
like yeah watch the video and I was
actually like we didn't end up filming
like my reaction because we were all
like just like what is this video but I
was like really nice when I was watching
it like you guys like hacking up you're
like me I'm got here like like such a
cool and I think he's so skilled I was
like oh my gosh like this is my work
from like six years back when I was 12
years old I believe it was discovered
but be like the nice things you learn
saying about it so that's really well
you saw how he discovered it it was yeah
you were recommended video in into the
youtube search bar like the exact title
of one of my videos like fire drill yeah
for real that's just like some weird the
universe thing where it was like we did
type in the title of your video yeah and
like I had not laughed like that in bed
long Howie I mean we had to cut it out -
we there was like laughing - but that's
like we sat down you know we were having
like a rough night that night like all
things are going wrong but Lainey that
is the kind of stuff on the internet
that I feel like so many people are
looking for and if you ever find it it's
like a gold bite it's like the perfect
mix of like this is funny and funky and
happy and like nice and like of course a
child made it cuz it's like so pure it's
like so everything that I want on the
internet I know but then all the plot
twists and the different murders yeah
it's like really yeah but I relate I
mean I relate to a certain extent
obviously I I never really got to
anything as a kid but my dad always had
cameras around so I would play yeah with
the cameras and people have even dug up
old videos I mean as a kid on YouTube
now and it's like super nursing but
that's like I totally understand like
you know as I kept getting into that so
it's super cool in that way you put your
mark on YouTube so long ago
yeah but also I'm also super sorry for
like blowing your spa I didn't think I
was gonna turn into that guys please be
respectful of Eric and his family in his
practice II dream to like become like a
YouTube famous person Elmo's and like
the way I like completely like I went to
high school like I hate like kind of
gave up on that okay I'm just gonna
study like business or whatever in
university and then writers you decided
you're done with it it comes back and
sneaks up on you
so yeah but no it's definitely something
that like if I have time in the future
or something like that I don't eat food
when I continue like making videos and
stuff cuz like I enjoy it that was like
my childhood hobby and then like when I
went to high school I like got more
interested in learning languages and
then also having to like do homework and
stuff but like that's I really like I
really like making videos and what I
made I don't know you saw you use the
same attacks like you brought it back
out of the heart video we were like what
is this gonna be and then and then you
pop there's like some trees kind of an
exaggerated version of like me coming
out of it with although I took my phone
in the car I don't like still on the
trail but um you know just like filming
that video like was so much fun I had
just gotten back to Pennsylvania like
Iceland home from Colorado and it was
literally the day I got home I got home
like 2:00 a.m. and I was like alright 10
am getting out I'm filming this video
and I filmed it and then I did the next
day and it was so much fun I was like
okay maybe I should like you didn't skip
a beat it looked like
it was like two days between your
hospital Oh
the only thing though is that you have
had the most amazing glow up Eric's look
beautiful I don't know it's like it's
really weird actually reading the
comments like yeah I guess it's a it's
also interesting I I probably haven't
seen my videos well I I'm sure I saw
them sometime in the last like four or
five years I have not before you
discover them like I did not see one of
my videos in a long time like I forgot
that I had made some of them and
something the one thing you're like
laughing do whatever like I don't know
I'm like I was in support of it so so
what are you what are you doing now
you're in school what do you study
so I'm studying international management
and minoring in German thing but you
additi on bilingual right yes well it's
so I speak English fluently and then
German pretty pretty well like highly
proficient same with Korea and I speak
Korean highly proficiently so what was
one when I look at building front yeah
what was the for you learning French was
here in Canada so he said yeah um so
Korean what sparked so from like the
beginning of middle school I guess
around the time actually I started
making videos um my one of my best
friends like she is Korean and so only
let's go I didn't really learn any
Korean actually I wanted to learn
Chinese in middle school it just cuz
like I knew some Chinese people I was
like okay like why not but we're middle
schooler it's like it was hard because
like actually I is weird I still
remember a lot of like random Chinese
phrases and like I can pronounce I'm
like decently well but um but in like
seventh or eighth grade I around the
time when I like with like really into
making my videos like it's not like
hires but
in college level I was like okay I'm
gonna like stop learning tiny A's and
like do nothing but then I was like wait
a second
Korean is like somewhat similar not
really what sort of and so I like
started learning Korean because my best
friend
Julie who she is Korean and she was like
oh the Korean language just it has a
phonetic alphabet like it doesn't look
like it's not English letters but um
it's still enough of it so then I
learned that in like this summer before
ninth grade and then from there I just
like studied it on my own like my friend
like instead of making videos that
detain like what I enjoyed and then two
years ago I went to Korea for almost a
month and I did like this exchange
program there so I got very good at
Korean and then like this past summer I
was in Korea again so we actually tweet
it out and they want to ask me questions
all right don't know dad don't be
skinned um I guess we better cover this
but where did you learn to do your fire
effects its right and you hurt yourself
where so actually I'm not a hundred
percent sure I think that probably was
like a little bit I think some of the
grind he goes like original videos had
like some of those kinds of effects and
like how I actually learned it is
straight up going to YouTube and
googling in the bar
like how to add fire effects premiere
pro yeah like that man is there like
nasty things to you were like getting
propagate this I was like later on so
like in like seventh or eighth grade um
I like for Christmas or whatever yeah
for Christmas I think it was I was like
to my parents I asked for like the Adobe
suite a really After Effects and
Premiere Pro and
I got the student discount do it like
even though actually for like you know
for a city students cuz like nobody
usually ever buys it in middle school
but it works like I even like my didn't
cook like code and everything I think we
had to like email ago because like don't
have like some poor middle school but we
got the student just got in any kids
which is good and it so then from there
I like did things like googling like how
to good after effects but actually I
think like in the dryer on fire video
and stuff like that um you could tell
that it's like not like very
professional maximally guy you
legitimately would just like use the
crop effect and then just like a
straight line profit since then though I
I have actually made other videos like
first of all projects a lot of times and
like in like my community I'll make
videos for them and stuff like that and
those if there is a need for a fire fact
I actually don't think I've ever done a
fire like really a fire but like I use
like like proper masking to him oh but
in the video that I made actually I
don't think I needed to mask anything
but I like tried to make it look still
like as if I made it back then like I
could have made some of the effects
better but I was like no I guess cheaper
it's a legit yeah speaking of that what
is your favorite video you ever made um
probably I think it's called Christmas
nightmare it's called something
different I mean the that was like the
second or third video that I made after
having like Adobe like the the sweet or
whatever because like that was difficult
that wood masking green screen for that
I don't think yeah no I didn't I Oh
besides it's like there aren't that many
scenes I guess and it's like not that
long on the video but there's not that
many scenes where all of us are like I
guess there are a lot of it but I just
remember I really like because I just
like didn't know how to use like the
like automatic like
masking abilities I should have just
used the like pen tool and with like
anybody Framus I said straight up a week
on that video but another good one knows
a good one that one I like actually pop
because you will get aside from the
impressive ending on Banasik and
shooting just filming takes a long time
you use you grab this because you just
murdered yourself in like the first 30
seconds and it came out of nowhere and
it was like holy [ __ ] we gotta watch
this now what is happening I feel like
you could put all of Eric's channel on
like Adult Swim and it would kill ya
it's very it's like very random and
shocking how did I ever like come up
with okay
I'm very basic like I like vanilla ice
creams I'm actually slightly lactose
intolerant so I usually don't scream but
yeah if I had to yeah I just do like
vanilla or like vanilla with chocolate
chips in it
he tries they have almond milk as pastor
you guys with you yeah yeah yeah I also
have like lactose free ice cream yeah
well we don't want to take too much time
we want first of all thank you so much
for like doing this thank you guys
inviting me yeah and obviously like you
know you're going to university so you
gotta you know live your life but the
internet wants to see you so if you ever
any idea fact yeah we'll be here
we'll be anxiously awaiting on you
lurking on your channel and also if you
if you ever have any questions or you
need help from us personally just reach
out you know yeah alright yeah
absolutely and I don't like expect too
much but I definitely
I'm not going to be done forever I'll
promise you guys that at least but um
when the next one will come out I don't
know it's nothing but yeah well thanks
so much I'm investing so much everyone
is like the biggest fan of yours we love
you notorious so yeah thank you a night
like all the comments like all of your
words they're so kind like thanks to you
and like everyone thanks for coming on
all the back ok bye
alright well there there it is that's
our that's our time we spent with Eric
I was almost he surprised how
comfortable he was like you know on
camera talking to us like he was pretty
comfortable it was almost like he was so
comfortable wearing me at ease or
something like if you want to look good
in your underwear and be comfy you can
get some ents - I can't believe you
segment a proud Poinsett sponsor of the
podcast and also newly a sponsor of the
twitch stream
immunity's is a team of amazing people
with an amazing product guys I'm not
wearing these theories on my lap these
are the awesome new one of the new
designs it feels like a whoopee looks
like three times off the cotton micromo
no fabric no I never had will be made
from sustainably sourced soft natural
fabric guys and for us mmm I I said to
Jenna last night I was getting dressed
in my in my closet ready I don't know
when the last time I didn't wear me
anything like I have only mere days at
this point and you I'm getting pretty
close it's it's crazy because like they
send us because we're on the
subscriptions you send it every month
but you never ever look in your drawer
for any of the underwear not not that
you would even find it because mine's
just so drowned out by me Andes and
that's the best problem in the world
guys me and he's is so soft once you try
it you're like gonna feel like what was
I doing this whole time they're so soft
comfortable and they look great they
have new designs every month really
really cool designs - and right now you
guys can get
20% off because you're the dink fan and
we got you so you're gonna me Andy's
calm / Jenna Julian get 20% off and free
shipping hundred percent guarantee and
the best softest underwear you've ever
worn and that is a real guarantee guys
check it out if you don't like your
first pair don't love your first pair
you'll get a full refund I guarantee
that's not gonna happen but there you go
check it out me and these awesome people
awesome product and if you're looking
for something to do make some money guys
lyft is looking for drivers and for
trying to drive for a ride-sharing
company why not go for the one that
chooses to treat its drivers right which
is lyft you can earn hundreds of dollars
per week and you don't have to wait to
get paid lyft has expressed pay which
lets you pay out almost instantly which
is oh my god how convenient is that like
you don't have to wait you just get
money a lot of it and don't forget the
tips guys you keep 100% of the tips you
earn and they add up fast lyft was the
first ride sharing platform with tipping
built right into the app and drivers had
been paying over two hundred million
dollars since that feature was
introduced think about that for a sec
guys
you sign up for lyft they even make
pickups easy they have the color-coded
amp sign so when you're picking up your
customer who's waiting on you they're
like hey that's my lyft I see the same
color on his car that's on my phone or
on her car that's on my phone
happy drivers guys means happy
passengers that's why nine and a ten
lyft rods get a perfect five-star rating
right now join the ride-sharing company
an incredible step it is it's a very
impressive staff yeah
everything about it yeah cuz these are
strangers yeah during the company that
believes in treating people better at
lyft calm that's ly ft.com slash
annejulien and score yourself a $500 new
driver bonus by signing up right now
Thank You lyft
thank you sponsors so so yes I know we
can talk about this I like I'm amazed at
how first of all that he's grown up
because I already feel so just like wild
up with pride it's just like a wonderful
young man you know like there's no other
way to describe him yeah he's like an
incredible talented wonderful sweet look
like
right yeah and he's clearly like so
talented at a lot of different things he
at this point has enough choices to last
him forever of what he would like to do
where he wherever he would like to spend
his brain power you know be successful I
mean he's the epitome of like a young
man who has in you know in growing up
spent his time efficiently and with with
care and not wasted any time not have
free time you know always staying busy
with things you know learn Korean before
the ninth grade found that to be a new
hobby which is as crazy as I'd like
something like that's really cool like
to find a language to be a new hobby he
was like you know that's kind of what
took over my free time I enjoyed it
that's what made me happy it's like
really cool so first of all on top of
everything it's really cool to see him
happy and succeeding yeah as a young as
a young man it's rad as hell to see him
like you know really just like
appreciate the Internet's love yes I
feel like I want to say a huge thank you
to the people that watch my videos I
know when I first started in YouTube it
was we've talked about this plenty of
times where it's like when you first
started started on YouTube you can't
really you have no control over who
watches your videos so sometimes your
audience can be kind of toxic in the
beginning like when we went on the h3 h3
podcast and he was talking to me about
you know is is it bad being a girl I
think it is in the beginning or anybody
in the beginning because people just
find you and they're kind of toxic so
yeah yeah at this point the people that
are watching my main channel videos I
want to say a huge thank you for those
of you who are there because you you
just want to watch something and you
know who I am and you care and you're
not there to just be a dick and I want
to say a huge thank you to the ding fam
and the people that watched that video
and work so kind to Eric and like when I
was like be respectful of his privacy
yeah you guys you guys have been really
fantastic and I want to thank you for
making this a positive experience for
him and not one that was stressing him
out and appointment his life where he
really did not need to feel that stress
obviously he's going to school like I'm
just I'm really grateful that you guys
have been so kind to him yeah you know
it's just it says a lot about this can
we have the DHing film on the podcast
your turn on my channel the twitch name
it all seems to kind of come together as
like a really community like group of
people yeah and yeah we appreciate that
because for him you know this was just a
really really fun lead-in to university
right like he has this kind of random
discovery by us on his channel from four
years ago gets tons of nice tweets gets
flooded with nice messages only saying
like hey could you make more videos and
that's about it which is really great
because you know the kid is well he's
not even really kid anymore
eric is enough he's an adult and and you
know I honestly I told him this as you
heard in the interview I told him I
relate to growing up you know just with
a camera because I always my dad I had
cameras everywhere so I you guys have
found all those cringy [ __ ] you know I
made with my brother and stuff but like
I relate to being a kid and making
really really goofy you know videos and
you know some of the videos that you
haven't even found I you know I put a
lot of time and editing them like in
early high school years and stuff I'm
pretty glad you haven't found him but
that challenge I relate to him on that
level which i think is really cool cuz
like I saw his old videos I see him now
and I'm like the glow up like I said I
feel like you know what I mean obviously
his glove was better than mine but
that's neither here nor there anyway
what we did anything surprise you about
like I well I was surprised that he had
mentioned that he was such a big fan of
Ryan Higa because I've got asthma I
thought well I thought Ryan he was like
a couple years younger than me I thought
maybe he was too young to have had that
be one of his bigger influences well I
think when he when Eric probably started
watching Ryan was when Ryan was already
kind of cooked rhpc yeah yeah it was
before the early run right so when he
said Ryan he got was like I'm thinking
this green exercise ball like when I
first started watching Ryan because it's
funny to me that you know I I'm like
Braz League on the internet we find Eric
I'm like dying laughing but he's
obviously considered he's what 10 years
younger than me and he has cited his
biggest influences as one of my biggest
influences
that's so like but that's the power
right he got I don't like it you've now
spanned over a decade of influencing
people that's all
basically two different generations I
mean it's the two different it's very
well but it's a funny piece just like
maybe that's why I love it so much is it
it's very good vibe
it has especially like in the early days
of Ryan's videos when he wasn't really
you know a pro or had the pro team of
anything you know he did what he could
but it was funny the bottom line is
about stupid humor right and it's that
tone of like it's silly it's fun there's
like nothing on high so we get shot
there's five of you of the couch yeah
and it's it's relaxing to watch it's
funny to watch yeah it just like takes
you know a nice little part of your day
to just smile like I'm sorry that sounds
so cheesy but it really is just nice
it's just a nice content I wasn't
surprised when he said his favorite
video he's ever made was the Christmas
one because when I watched it I was like
not only like even if he did use green
screen having placing all of him on the
couch [ __ ] ever it takes a week to
edit which I don't it's crazy
I [ __ ] love that I've only done that
on a smaller scale and it takes forever
I think the closest we've done that
together has been your roasts yourself
yeah we did a lot of green screen and
masking on that but masking is is such
an intricate thing with video right you
have to you know it's it's painstaking
sometimes it takes hours and hours and
hours to literally get three seconds of
a shot to look right and he got the
whole video it's really impressive I
agree I honestly I I wanted to mention
Nathan said to him because Nathan's ed
is someone who's going to school and
currently maintaining an internet
presence not that you know Eric has to
maintain any sort of presence I'm just I
think it would be cool for him to see
that people do go to university and make
videos when they not the only one he's
just a really good example he's a good
to be a college student and have
priorities that do not include the
internet you know but also sometimes
when he yeah sometimes yeah yeah but I
you know with that said I think it would
be cool to see you know a video here and
there from him if he's if he's willing
you know obviously he seems like his
heart still in it Ricky you know it
seems like this sort of brought a little
life
into that kind of passion area but we'll
see you know I just think it was cool
that we spoke with him I okay really
full circle you know yeah seriously it's
I don't know it's it's just really cool
and I feel I feel proud of Erick even
though we just met him via Skype I feel
proud of him I want him to be happy and
I want all the good things to happen to
him yeah you know and I just again I
want to say thank you to you guys for
being so kind and yeah you know and and
we really you know we expect nothing
less in the future from you guys to
continue to be supportive and nice
regardless if he makes a videos or not
will link his stuff below so you can
feel free to follow him but yeah you
know if he makes videos great if he
doesn't great to you just living his
life yeah out in Canada speaking Korean
is so cool about wait what it's pretty
[ __ ] rad so I hope you guys are happy
we really wanted to make that happen
and we did so yeah well is that it we're
gonna link his channel I will link his
channel he's got a new channel cuz I
think you to block them out of the old
one or something yeah will link them
both in case you want to check out any
of those older videos yeah this is cool
we had our first good first step yes
also let us know and it was a super
ghetto setup on how we recorded it and
[ __ ] we'll work on that for the future
but let us know if you've had any ideas
for other Skype guests that we could
feasibly
bring on the podcast because that was
fun but you guys have a wonderful week
yeah and we love you I love you Eric's
family and we'll catch you guys
[Music]